[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me bring in the guy who has all the
answers
the great uh sports business columnist
for the new york post andrew marchand
all right explain the logic behind this
deal andrew
well number one espn has been trying to
get peyton manning forever
i called him the white whale uh you know
moby dick style um trying to get peyton
uh to do monday night football he's not
wanted to go into the booth
uh you know he's made that pretty
apparent um no matter what they've
offered so
this is a way to get him into the booth
he brings eli with them they'll add a
host uh and so if you're gonna further
that relationship that espn has with
peyton
they already do peyton's places which
from what i'm told is one of the more
successful espn plus programs they've
made others with dave ortiz and
and eli and abby womback to do other
sports
and they'll probably add to that as well
so now they increase that relationship
they get the great headline and now now
they got to make it a good show
does it bastardize though the monday
night football
broadcast well
look i think on the surface it's not a
good day for steve levy brian greasy and
lewis redicks are the main team
but they've really been kind of viewed
as the
the second um but it's just they haven't
really
they kind of got the job with these kind
of um
you know just here you guys take it they
tried to get you know
um peyton manning last year
um and then they tried to get others
they're gonna go out they went hard
after tony romo and
instead they've uh they sort of uh they
were the second choice so
in that regard yeah it's not great for
them but uh but they do uh
uh i do think there's a way where if
depending how peyton and eli do
how well they do that it could it could
shine well on stephen company
who are they going to add as are they
going to have an actual play-by-play
voice or a host
of this yeah they're going to have a
host not a play-by-play guy so
um are you available dan yes i am
okay so i will set up that negotiation
okay thank you very well thank you
i know you have a good relationship with
espn um and so uh
the but they do need somebody honestly
though someone like you
um you know they had some people
in-house uh
i could see svp i could see a young guy
like ryan rucco
uh they could go outside i know uh you
think the same way i do about i and
eagle and i don't know if he signed up
with cbs but
you need someone look if this is going
to be successful it's going to be
probably more about who that
third person is that hosts to make it
all work
than it will be about peyton and eli i
mean peyton and eli are going to see
things on the field
they're going to be someone you know
probably pretty entertaining but
you know they are uh you know how high
is the bar and the other thing about
this type of show
is you really have to do it well you
have to produce it well it's not
it sounds like oh you just put peyton
and eli out there
um you talk for three hours you gotta
have some plans you can't just
be willy-nilly and i know they'll
probably get a big name guest and that
could be interesting
but uh but you really have to produce
this well in the host you have to get
everything right
it's not it's not to me it's not a slam
thunk i mean i think it's great for espn
that they were able to pull this off but
for it to be successful is not a slam
dunk
is aaron rodgers in play for any of the
networks if he decides that he's
going to retire sit out whatever his
game plan is
i mean i think they might make a call i
don't really see it he doesn't strike me
as that
type of guy that wants to to do that
especially if he was just
out of football for maybe a year i guess
if he retired and said that's it that
doesn't seem to be the game plan
although i have no
inside info on that i just don't he
he doesn't strike me as a guy you know
but
they always make the call uh you know if
when they can they can try to upgrade
because
you know for whatever reason this the
broadcasting the nfl obviously
is the most popular uh programming on tv
but the broadcasters the analyst i mean
those are sought after job and
starting with role model 180 million for
10
those jobs pay well andrew great to talk
to you again great work on this thanks
for joining us
thanks dan that's andrew marchand new
york post sports business columnist
glad he's throwing my hat into the ring
here to maybe host this on on monday
night